ils étaient des milliers à faire la file
les plus courageux sont arrivés à l'aube
tous sont attendus le temps qu'il
fallait parfois pendant des heures pour
défiler devant le cercueil de leur idole
guy lafleur a laissé sa marque
littéralement dans le coeur de bien des
partisans ils sont venus d'un peu
partout de tous les horizons de toutes
les générations pour lui dire au revoir
une dernière fois c'est une personne qui
est très inquiète toujours été
disponible late le pour lui aujourd'hui
liste neige en hauteur saut puis ces
quartiers thomas ne l'ait pas vu jouer
mais il a un moment de communion
collective pour la province le québec
pleure l'un des plus grands héros
sportif de son histoire les victimes un
gilet nordique
c'était bien agréable de devoir son sort
de retour au jeu mais avec le canadien
et les choisit souvent rapporté les
cop's année par le scoop stade les
chauves tagi 7,6 glisser dans une
ambiance solennelle guy lafleur repose à
côté de sa famille en chapelle ardente
est aussi des trophées qui ont bâti sa
gloire sa renommée mais c'est sa
personnalité qui a laissé une trace
indélébile et il y avait pas la langue
de boer et puis j'en parlais avec son
épouse a pas toujours été fait c'est là
que jean le cam avec le canadien
bon donc et il s'est mis des fois tu
trouves ça m'arrive mais aussi
d'ailleurs et
c'est ça what you see is what you get
guy lafleur nous rendait fier c'est un
homme qui était fier c'est un joueur de
raki très fier très talentueux elle va
avoir marqué beaucoup de monde par sa
générosité par son authenticité sa
passion et bien sûr son talent a un
talent hors norme qui lui a valu cinq
coupes stanley trois championnats des
marqueurs et surtout un vedettariat
instantanée sans jamais pour autant lui
faire oublier ses vieux compagnons
d'armes monde y envoyer des cadeaux aux
instituts du prenez les cadeaux pu
donner à notre personnel de chiens il
voulait s'assurer que notre monde on
entrerait à choix heureux qu'ils
faisaient ils prenaient lille prenait
bien soin de tout le monde tout le monde
me dit aujourd'hui
tout en plus soin de moi donc nous on
était chanceuse dégâts 3e 4e salon
a pris soin au dos et une générosité qui
lui a toujours permis de se faire
pardonner ses excès en tous genres nuit
et j'ai levé le 9
août une aile la fontaine
vieux port de québec
59 une vie à 100 milles à l'heure au
cours de laquelle il n'aura laissé
personne indifférent
ici alexandre gasco radio-canada à
montréal